all right what's up everybody
it is november 24th in the year
2020 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message
there's a lot going on as there seems to
be
these days before i do anything else
though i have to
i have to have a bit of a maya culpa i
have to
issue an apology because uh something
happened yesterday
and i feel that if i don't acknowledge
it now
it will just spin and and get worse and
worse and worse and one day
could potentially destroy me a scandal
and the whole thing so here it is
um last night at about
10 15 um i took
my dog clyde out for a walk um
i know we're not supposed to i know
we're supposed to
remain in our homes trapped like rats
from 10 p.m
to 5 a.m as per the orders from
commander newsome
but clyde was looking at me we were we
were sitting on the couch and clyde was
glancing at me and i was watching
seinfeld it was the soup nazi episode
actually
um there's so much talk about nazis now
and
he's looking at me and it was just
obvious that just letting him out to pee
wasn't enough
he really needed some exercise and he's
he's about a year and a half and he's a
boxer and part pit and there's a lot of
energy there
and i thought i'm not gonna just let him
in the backyard i'm gonna take him out
for a walk so
at about 10 15 last night i dave rubin
of los angeles california took my dog
out for a walk so look let the chips
fall where they may it's like
are the stormtroopers going to be
banging at the door while we're doing
this live stream maybe
and will i have done it to myself i i
suppose um
so if if that's what happens and they
throw me in the gulag i just want to say
it's been a pleasure
getting to know you guys i hope that
i've provided a little sanity
in the storm and somebody
come to my house and and take clyde and
just walk them earlier in the day
okay uh all right now that we've got
that out of the way and again if the
stormtroopers come we'll
just pause the live stream and i'll just
i'll just walk out
uh okay a bunch of stuff i want to talk
about today lockdowns are expanding all
over the place i'm actually
only going to focus on la for just a
little bit because there's some really
crazy stuff
happening in new mexico where they're
actually shutting down grocery stores
and walmarts
and all sorts of stuff it's like okay
we're going to lock people in their
houses
and also make sure they don't have
access to essential goods that really
makes a lot of sense
that's the first story we're covering
today number two
you all know about the big gavin newsom
dinner up at french laundry one of the
most expensive restaurants in the entire
united states
well originally when the story leaked
they said it was 12
people it was outdoors there were social
distancing masks
blah blah blah it all turns out to be
nonsense uh
there is a reporter and we'll get into
it says 22 people were there no masks no
social distancing and get this guys
get this you know how much the alcohol
bill was the bar bill the booze bill
15 000 dollars
that is about seven hundred fifty
dollars a person
in alcohol wine booze i'm a wine guy i
like good wine and i don't begrudge
people that work hard for a living
spending their money as such uh
but newsome we're gonna have to discuss
a little bit about you
in just a moment uh and then finally you
know as we're seeing
sort of the mainstream media kind of
recalibrate right now like they really
feel like the biden thing is here and
they're very excited
to get on their knees and and fellate
him endlessly
and the empire um i i found this thread
by
a journalist the guy by the name of jake
sherman who's a nbc journalist and a
politico journalist
and i'm just going to read the whole
thing to you because
you need to see a perfect example of how
these people are not
journalists but they're activists and i
didn't even need to use air quotes
around activists
but before we get to any of that guys i
want to talk to you
about second thoughts i've got it right
here in my hand
second thoughts is this year's new
favorite party game that's sure to be
the hit
of your next game night at some point
the election results will be official
i don't know when but it'll be more
necessary than ever to connect with
family and friends over some
light-hearted fun
david and i always host thanksgiving
we're doing it again this year as you
guys know and we're looking forward
to playing some second thoughts after a
delicious
turkey dinner we got a record-breaking
huge turkey
the play of the game calls for each team
to quickly create a list of words for
their opponents to decipher
leading to hilarious puzzlement and
laughter
simply put guys it's a classic word
guessing game with a unique twist that
allows players
to personalize the content with their
voluminous sense of word smithery
or just their witty and warped
imaginations each round of second
thoughts is a hilarious high speed
attempt to stump the other team
both teams create a list of five things
using the letters revealed from the
color dice
be witty and wise but don't take too
long because time is not on your side
the amount of time it takes your team to
create the list is exactly how much time
your opponents get to guess them
this game gets really fun after a glass
or two or three of
whiskey or wine good for gavin newsom
second thoughts the quick thinking verse
fast talking party game and for the
month of november guys the game will be
on sale at a special price so be sure
to get yours today at second
thoughtsthegame.com that's second
thoughts
thegame.com or at your local target
store and now back to me
okay let's let's talk about lockdowns
i'm going to get us out of california
you know i focus a lot on california
here because
we are the the most psychotic state i
think there's a study that proved that
new york's close but uh california is up
there and it's oddly i've only lived in
new york and california
and yet here i am so i don't know what
that says about me i should probably see
a therapist
uh but let's talk about new mexico uh
because new
new mexico governor michelle lujan
gisham
is now shutting down groceries for two
weeks
after a spike in covid19 cases so let's
get the quote
from the washington examiner quote a
dozen grocery stores around the state
have been forced to close for two weeks
because of a public health
order issued by governor michelle
illusion
grisham at a time when the state's
residents are suffering from record high
unemployment and food insecurity critics
say
now they've also closed a couple
walmarts they've got people standing in
lines all over the place
you can feel this kind of all over the
country right now suddenly like toilet
paper
and paper towels are suddenly in short
order and the and the
you know the stock is low and all that
kind of stuff um
so look i'll do this at the broad level
i think you know my feelings about
lockdowns at this point there there is
no evidence that lockdowns work there's
no evidence that keeping people trapped
in their homes work
we know actually that it's increasing
suicide and it's increasing depression
and it's increasing alcoholism and all
sorts of other bad behaviors and we know
that people are actually gaining weight
they're not going to the gym as much
they're they're not acting as healthy
there's all sorts of mental health stuff
we know all this stuff
but now we've shifted this to not just
closing malls
and closing you know just
the shoe store and restaurants we're
actually closing
grocery stores now this is a dozen
roughly a dozen stores in new mexico and
there may be a little more to the story
there may be a little more to the story
but this [ __ ]
doesn't fly anymore and we the people
better start realizing what's going on
here what right
does your governor or your mayor have to
tell you you cannot
provide for your family in essence
that's what they're saying and by the
way
you know what two days from now is two
days from now is thanksgiving the
holiday where we
in america give thanks for the freedoms
we have
for the incredible 250 year history
of joy and freedom and and
goodness and richness that we have that
is the jealousy the world
over and as we roll into thanksgiving we
are
under the most extraordinary
authoritarian lockdowns
basically in the history of america this
is this is prohibition on steroids this
is
this is it's just extraordinary and
speaking of prohibition by the way we're
not even covering this story today
but the dingbat governor of pennsylvania
has decided that
uh starting tomorrow at i think 5 p.m
there'll be no alcohol sales
for for thanksgiving like none of this
makes sense
there's no science that says that you
can't have alcohol on thanksgiving
during a pandemic
or that you can't buy it just the day
before i mean there's gonna be a lot of
people buying alcohol today like
none of it makes sense and we're
pretending it all makes sense but this
idea of the grocery stores
and shutting down you know a place like
walmart like these are places where
people get essentials they get
they get diapers you don't just get food
at a grocery store right there's other
essentials you might get some medicine
there you might get band-aids all sorts
of stuff
and we are just letting these people do
these things
and i don't know what it's going to take
for the average person to wake up but as
i said yesterday my hope
is that we're just going to start seeing
lots of little tea parties popping up
all
over the united states it may not be
organized
what i mean by that is the spirit the
spirit of the tea parties that
individual people
and their local families and groups will
start banding together
and say no more of this no more of this
we covered two stories yesterday
about how people are doing that we saw
the the people up in
buffalo who were kicking the the
regulators out of their
establishment because they had no right
to be there that was great and then we
saw the woman yelling at
uh you know what's his name uh jersey
governor murphy
and it's like i don't like people
yelling at each other in public places
i think it's a little bit different with
uh with public figures rather than than
private citizens
anyway none of this is going away but
let's let's shift this
uh to story number two for a moment
because the gavin newsom the the famous
dinner at french laundry
the thousand dollar a plate dinner well
the story gets even better
so this is from adam housley who is a
fox news
correspondent uh he uncovered that there
were a couple things there first off
newsome lied
because there were 22 people at the
dinner not 12 people now
this is at the same time where he's
telling you that you peon
shouldn't have more than 10 people over
and you have to do this stuff outside of
course they were indoors and you can see
the picture with the gorgeous chandelier
and the fancy carpet and the mirrors and
the whole thing
not indoors he also said
adam housley that there was no social
distancing surprise surprise
and that there were they weren't using
masks no surprise there
but the real kicker the real kicker of
this story
is not that french laundry is super
expensive and not that people go to
expensive restaurants i've been to some
expensive restaurants
in my day and if that's how you choose
to spend your money that's fantastic and
that's on you that's wonderful i'm a big
food guy you guys
follow me on on social media you see i'm
always posting pictures of steaks and
all sorts of fun stuff that that's just
great and i love good wine
too i'm not besmirching the good people
of napa and sonoma and yachtville i'm
really not
um but gavin newsom at this dinner
where there were 22 people indoors not
12 people
not outdoors their bar bill
that's the bill for the booze that's the
wine bill people it was
fifteen thousand dollars
for 22 people now i'm not a math
magician here but that's about 750 bucks
per person in booze now that's that's
some seriously expensive wine and again
i don't begrudge them that
i believe in capitalism i believe you're
allowed to spend your hard earned money
however you wish but the irony of this
wannabe little dictator
telling us stay at home don't celebrate
thanksgiving we're locking you down
we're shutting
your restaurants and your businesses and
all of those things and what do we do
while we're doing it we spend fifteen
thousand dollars on expensive wine at
the exact same time
so you know i wrote out a line here for
gavin newsom
and i i have my fancy glasses because i
want to i want to get this just right so
gavin i wrote it out here so that i can
get it just right but i do want to speak
directly to you gavin newsom
go [ __ ] yourself
that was good that was good that felt
right to me that felt right to me you
know i try not to drop the f-bomb that
often you know i'm not
i'm not like that shapiro guy he's
afraid of saying it he won't say it
publicly
but i felt that that you know try it
again
gavin newsom
go [ __ ] yourself
it's better than cnn over here people
i'm telling you all right uh let's talk
about the third story
let's just move on for a second oh no
sorry i want to jump back for just a
little
little bonus on this story because these
lockdowns are happening all over the
place
uh this is a a video i saw this on
twitter it was catch and fire but of
course you're not going to see it on cnn
of course you're not going to see it
anywhere mainstream oh i think you'll
see why you should see it there
this is from a twitter user called at
the right melissa
on twitter who i noticed she actually
does she does follow me
and uh i believe and we tried to find
some more info on this
but i believe this is from california
and as you know we've got this 10
o'clock
curfew here now and this video is from
two days ago let's take a look
it's not you guys aclu is fine get off
the street
go home go home go home or you're
getting arrested
you're under arrest
is
[Music]
i can't help it
i mean if you don't think that that is
chilling
if you don't think that that is
disturbing if you don't think that that
is evil then i don't know what to say to
you now there might be some more context
we're trying to find out a little bit
more
but the line there go as the as the
officer is charging this man who's
standing there in his bathrobe
apparently a little bit after 10 pm go
home
or you're getting arrested dot dot dot
as the guy says well what what's going
on
curfew did that seem like a a
responsible or sensible response to
somebody be
standing outside of their home after 10
pm in a free society did that seem right
to you
but yet we not only allow this to happen
mainstream won't even show that now the
irony of course
is that i thought we have a problem with
police brutality in this country don't
we have a problem with these evil police
officers who are murdering innocent
people all over the place and abusing
their power and authority isn't that
isn't that a thing uh well i guess not
in this case
because the guy happened to be white and
he was breaking the 10 pm curfew which
the powers that be really love so they
won't even
they won't even show you this clip so
obviously there may be a little more
context there
but i think you have enough to know that
there's a guy just standing there
and also the way that the the officer
sort of points to the
to the cameraman and says oh you're okay
and oh and acl you guys are okay to
break curfew
but this guy's not okay to break her if
you like how do they decide who's
allowed to break curfew or not
and if this pandemic was so serious if
the virus
was spreading all over the place and
just killing swaths of people
and not the didn't have the 99 recovery
rate that it has plus the
the vaccines that are on the way uh well
then wouldn't you want everybody inside
you wouldn't want the cameraman
or the aclu or anyone else oh and by the
way
watch the video again the assaulting
officer who's committing the assault
right there
he's not wearing a mask not wearing a
mask no mask
but no no mask no mask
anyway guys i i mentioned this again i'm
not trying to outrage you with these
things what i'm trying to do is just
wake you up to some of the nonsense that
mainstream media just
won't cover um so you should find that
video for yourself
watch check the thread see what people
are saying find out more for yourself
but like
just this is the broader point the
broader point is a mainstream as i say
with so many of the things
about the election so many of the things
that are just going on that we all know
because of the internet for now at least
because i think the social media
bannings are coming soon um
we know all these things and the media
chooses to ignore them and then that
creates that schism that schism that
leads us to the to the reality war that
i'm always talking about all right
speaking of reality war journalists as i
always say have destroyed journalism
what i mean by this
is over the last four years we have
basically seen
that most people who consider themselves
journalists are not in fact journalists
they're they're democrat
operatives that that is just very very
obvious
and you can see it for four years people
that were screaming about
orange man bad and hitler is coming and
all of these things
you can suddenly see how much nicer
they're being because they think they
have their guy in the
in the oval office coming their incoming
administration and biden it's going to
be democrats again and democrats are
good
and republicans are bad and this is why
i kept saying the biggest
the biggest thing that trump did was
show republicans how to fight back and
if trump
in fact does lose now um i i don't know
what that means for the future of the
republican party
by the way i still don't think the
election's fully over i still think
there's some more surprises like
this is 20 20 people if you don't think
that it's got a couple surprises left
i don't know what to tell you because
this year is the year of the surprise
right
uh but i found this twitter thread this
morning that's so perfectly encapsulated
what is wrong
with modern journalism that it is this
activist
and as candace owen says they're not
they're not she doesn't call them
activists she calls them hitmen
but in essence what they are they're
very thinly guys
journalists who really are just
providing activism and pushing their own
narrative constantly so this is a
twitter thread by this guy jake sherman
now his name's come up in my twitter
thread every now and again i don't
follow him
but he is a journalist from nbc and
politico
and i want to pull up this whole thread
that he had this morning because it's
just so perfect and such a perfect
example of what i'm talking about about
how they cheerlead their guys and they
try to destroy the other guys
so jake sherman he wrote playbook the
biggest shift and
by the way note as i read this that this
guy writes
as if he's writing the preamble to star
wars with selective
capitals you know you have to
selectively capitalize certain words the
first order
it's coming back the biggest shift in
washington in january won't only
be that democrats are taking the white
house it will be that the biden
administration will be
as brendan buck points out delightfully
boring
now that doesn't really strike me as a
statement of journalism it's a it's an
editorial right there
harris politico calls it joe biden's
team of careers now he then lists out
a bunch of people that that biden is
potentially bringing into the
administration okay
this is an admin filled with people who
have deep experience in government
and in the agencies they will be running
the post puts it this way
by design they seem meant to protect a
dutiful competence as biden creates
a government overseen by those who have
run it before sounds like a pr
piece so far they believe in a linear
plotting purposeful
and standard policy process impulsive
policymaking and widespread leaks
from competing factions in the
administration
are probably over expect interviews with
joe biden to be a big deal
meaning they won't happen that often
which gives them an extra oomph
will complain and they won't care his
interview with lester holt
on nbc will air tonight i think that
one's particularly interesting because
he's basically carrying water knowing
biden can't really do interviews because
there's something wrong
with him cognitively and we all know it
so he's basically they're already
leading us
joe won't even have to be seen that much
because his team is going to be so
competent
that actually once a month when they let
him out from the basement
and they hop him up on adderall or
whatever they're doing with him then
then we'll let him speak uh but two more
here and then i think he'll really see
the point
we can't imagine he'll pop into the
briefing room with regularity
or tweet his emotions thoughts or
decision-making processes
statements of administration policy sap
statements of administration policy
will again be a big deal because it will
be how you know what the administration
is thinking on legislation so he's
they're already telling you
the guy won't pop out for uh for talks
he's not gonna take questions they're
telling you we're gonna
do his job we're gonna carry water for
him he's our guy and then finally
this was the best part you probably
won't get conflicting signals from the
white house about whether the president
will sign a bill
if he works on it and is part of the
agreement he probably won't veto
it at the last minute sorry that wasn't
the last part were there
uh oh you know i don't have it here can
you pull up that last part of it i'll
grab it here i think i lost a sheet of
paper because it's just so perfect
people
bear with me for one second i'm working
hard over here today
the last part of the thread says this i
almost got it here one second sorry guys
um okay it is unlikely to be an
administration that has aids rushing to
get on tv to praise the president
in fact you will rarely see many of many
of these cabinet officials so now
they're saying we're not only going to
hide biden and not ask to see him but
we're also going to hide
the officials do you see how twisted
this is how
freaking twisted this is but here here
was the end of it
this is just so perfect this is just
over if you have a
barf bag any of you have barf bags if
any of you have been flying lately you
know they leave a barf bag in the seat
pocket in front of you you may want to
grab the barf bag because this is barf
bag worthy
in other words if the trump white house
was like
downing a vat of tabasco sauce over the
past four years the biden white house
will be like
sipping unflavored almond milk
this man jake sherman is pretending to
be a journalist he is a democratic
operative who's setting the stage
so that they'll never have to ask the
president questions they'll never have
to ask his minister administration
questions
trump remember that that was like
drinking tabasco sauce because we
had to work and we don't like orange man
but now we will sip
almond milk first off who sips almond
milk i put a little almond milk in my
coffee sometimes but who's sipping
almond milk
but all of that aside do you see what
this is you see why i wanted
to to read this twitter thread to you
it's not to make it about this one guy
because
every day there are a plethora an
unending
splurge of these types of twitter
threads and stories from journalists
but i think the biggest story of 2021
going forward will be if if joe biden is
to be president i'm still putting the if
there and we still got to see
what uh sydney powell's got we still got
to see what trump's team's got with
giuliani and jen ellis and everything
else the election is not certified
and i still think surprises are coming
as i just said but i think really the
biggest story of 2021 will be how
quickly
the media will just go back to being
subservient
pets and lap dogs to the democrats and
then what will be even more dangerous
than that and mark my words on this guys
is that if biden is president january
20th
that slowly after that we are going to
see mass social media bannings because
what they're going to do is they're
going to want to continue lockdowns
and they will start making it seem that
if you are not pro
lockdown or if you are tweeting
anti-lockdown stuff or doing videos that
are anti-lockdown
they will make it seem like you are now
a threat to public health
and then the policies of the social
media companies will be to ban new
people that it's it's all coming
like it's all coming i don't think this
is paranoia or anything else the best
chance we have of stopping it
is talking about it now so that's
exactly why i'm doing it but by the way
uh if if you're worried about the
bannings and you want to stay in touch
with me
we did i did start a tech company in the
midst of all this i don't i don't just
talk about these things i actually do
things
and we started locals because of this
and you can go to reubenreport.com which
is powered by locals and
directly communicate with me that's
where i actually respond to people
because
obviously it's impossible to do on the
other things that are just overloaded
with bots and trolls and
haters and blah blah blah anyway guys uh
be sure to check out part one of my
interview with nicole arbour which went
up yesterday people are absolutely
loving her you're not gonna believe this
she's a comedian
who's absolutely funny she's actually
funny it's it
you thought it was dead but it's back
nicole arbour is a funny comedian
i'm gonna try to get on tour with her
when this nonsense ends at some point
um they we will be live streaming
tomorrow guys tomorrow wednesday
and then we're shutting it down for
thanksgiving and on friday i want my
guys to have off and
and i want to take off and and enjoy
some food and some family and friends
and
and i hope you guys uh will not be
uh online too much on thursday and
friday and even into the weekend like
let's escape some of the madness
and uh you know be around food
family and friends those are three of
the best four f's
see what i did there all right guys see
you tomorrow